what does this guy eat
he'll probably anything he wants
anything he wants of course yeah big
rats rabbits guinea pigs whatever uh you
know there's a necessity you know a
necessity for his diet in captivity
amazing in a while they'll eat you know
deers and they'll eat a small rodents
birds monkeys there have been cases
where some people have been killed by
these guys crazy but it's not like a
nice thing ain't like a crazy thing
that's happening every single day you
know yeah I think it's only one real
document of a actual person being inside
of a when I was recently correct three
of them yeah but that's that's good for
mice for our time on earth
don't worry buck you know I didn't bring
anything for you guys would get hurt I
promise I know it doesn't sound cool
when I got a 15th place snakes with in
by your feet but yeah it here the thing
listen I said I breathe that's their
breathing yeah yeah I think this big
snake has a big long yeah no yeah you
can hear it in a parking lot
really yeah and what's that mean when he
hisses back the [ __ ] up yeah you know
let's talk you know we've gotta stick
around you want it you want to bring him
out in a wreck with him later yeah okay
let's do that
yeah ain't no way we're gonna bring
these big animals in here they're gonna
be moving around 24/7
crazy crazy oh my god yeah the skin is
really beautiful
what you can't be so fun on his house
too much to bring the now you want you
this will give that guy a smaller snake
you would have I wouldn't at that side
this is called an African pixie frog
pixie frog oopsie frog what the [ __ ]
she do he's a big ass frog from Africa
sick right lazy you ever seen a frog
that big no no it's pretty amazing
of course he lives in like puddles of
water and stuff mm-hmm that's awesome
let's go get some questions so tell us
about this frog right here it's an
African African pickax rock these guys
of course come from Africa and you have
different species of frogs like pac-man
frogs and bullfrogs and tree frogs now
these guys live in LA look it's a fly
just flew on top of him
this fly doesn't have a clue he won't
even bother that fly yeah not enough for
ya
but these guys are cool about them I
live in Africa and I live in small
puddles of a like okay so you have a big
lake right uh-huh
and then say it rains you got like a
little small puddle over here this frog
there's a female will occupy that little
puddle she'll meet with her mate and
then she'll come in and she'll lay all
her tadpoles
in this little estuary a little small
place and these temples are raised up
and the male's job is to actually dig a
canal trench although I've seen this
lake yeah you seen it on Nat Geo yes so
they they dig basically a canal way
passage wait for the water to drain
through the tadpoles living there bigger
but they have to raise them up a little
bit because you know you lay them out in
the big you know open Lakes and you got
a lot of predatory fish or birds and
stuff that eats them yeah they can have
a little small lagoon they can stay in
they could protect them you know and
anything I wants to eat those little
small tadpoles
the Big Daddy can come here this thing
eats rats and snakes and crazy birds and
scorpion anything that comes by him I
hate to do it looks like that's for sure
[Music]